ooh you have to get up now something
really really awesome to show you
t-shirt dick on my face we are going to
call this in for your birthday we
deserve this I'll order asses on yep
it's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
tomorrow [ __ ] beach you're not
hitting up our dog's party we have to
see Roderick sober ladies speaking
morning why'd you get [ __ ] up we're
just like hang from it and say hey
[Music]
is this seriously how you can work Joe
her highest [ __ ] you cannot leave me
alone here because I will literally die
hey you know I'm disappointed you two
were right honey
[Music]
working hard entertaining this hair one
of the only things about this place I
don't hate go do something with your
lives
I'm not going anywhere without you what
the [ __ ] are you doing that's a decency
y'all are dirty dirty girls up
hey so what's to know you wanna know
stupid not be able to see god damn
that's it for today's episode [ __ ]
jail oh yeah no I told you I couldn't I
thought you went last night just don't
bury seen that place you know that
that's not healthy
[Applause]
you
you